[Musique]
les grands singes c'est vraiment capital
pour moi de faire tout pour les protéger
le braconnage c'est une chasse illégale
et les grands singes sont souvent des
victimes collatérales
[Musique]
le bonobo il est une espèce
malheureusement en danger d'extinction
si on n'est pas capable de protéger nos
plus proches cousins qu'est-ce qu'on va
réussir à faire alors avec le reste de
la biodiversité
dans cette vidéo je vous emmène au coeur
du continent africain pour vous parler
de la situation des grands singes
les grands singes c'est un ensemble
d'espèces de primates non humains qui
comprend les chimpanzés les bonobos les
gorilles de l'est les gorilles de
l'ouest et les espèces d'orangs outans
il ya trois espèces d'orangs outans
maintenant et leurs caractéristiques par
rapport aux autres primates non humains
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas de queue il
marche sur les phalanges ou sur les
points contrairement aux autres petits
singes qui marche sur les paumes et ils
ont une taille du cerveau relativement à
leur corps plus importante que les
autres espèces sauf qu'aujourd'hui la
plupart des grands singes sont en train
de disparaître et les primatologues
rencontre énormément de difficultés sur
le terrain pour les protéger et pour
bien comprendre cette problématique je
suis parti en république démocratique du
congo pour découvrir lola ya bonobo le
seul sanctuaire au monde qui recueille
et soigne des bonobos
[Musique]
on
donc ça c'est l'enclos le premier groupe
bonobos qui occupe une superficie de
forêts de 10 hectares c'est un groupe
paisible composé de 22 individus c'est
des orphelins qui sont sauvées rescapé
du massacre
après la mort de leurs parents des
bonobos c'est une espèce du même genre
que les chimpanzés
la caractéristique des bonobos c'est
d'abord qu'ils vivent que en république
démocratique du congo on les trouve
seulement dans ce pays et ils sont comme
les chimpanzés très proche de l'homme
globalement ils sont considérés comme
plus tolérant plus pacifique avec
notamment un rôle très important des
femelles dans la société de bonobo ce
sont des femelles qui dirige l'objectif
c'est en fait grâce à l'alliance des
phénomènes qui se tissent dans le groupe
c le pouvant maintenir la bonne cohésion
la discipline surtout entraîné mal à
chaque fois qu'il ya un conflit il ne
dispute faire des négociations par
approche sexuelle ils se mettent
ensemble ils font l'amour est dans la
guerre et ça c'est un acte qui se
déroule en paix elle même parce que ça
implique les mâles entre eux fm elle
entraîne mes grands et petits
tous les ans début de groupes sont
impliqués parce que à chaque fois qu'il
ya un stress en soudant le groupe
doivent s'apaiser se calme
les bonobos ils sont à 90% végétariens
les 10 % qui restent et équilibrée par
des insectes des oeufs du miel il fonce
héricourt à la viande c'est très rare
bien sûr sanctuaire ils sont nourris
principalement aux fruits et aux légumes
[Musique]
toutes les espèces de grands singes sont
en danger le bonhomme en fait partie on
estime les populations minimal actuel
entre quinze et vingt mille individus
mais c'est une estimation basse la
difficulté de
mieux connaître la taille de la
population c'est de pouvoir faire un
échantillonnage dans tout le pays ce qui
est très difficile donc en fait on sait
pas exactement mais on est sûr que entre
2003 et 2015 environ plus de 50% de la
population a disparu
[Musique]
pourquoi ils sont menacés
là encore c'est assez commun avec toutes
les espèces de grands singes
de manière générale on parle de la
déforestation qui bien sûr va entraîner
une perte d'habitat mais aussi une
fragmentation de l'habitat mais aussi la
mise en place par exemple de route dans
le cadre de l'exploitation forestière ou
de l'exploitation minière qui peut
favoriser la deuxième menace qui est le
braconnage
le braconnage est une chasse illégale
qui peut avoir plusieurs objectifs comme
capturer des orphelins vivant pour
ensuite les revendre au marché noir ou
tuer des espèces ciblées pour récupérer
ce qu'on appelle de la viande de brousse
comme celle des singes et cette viande
elle peut être consommée soit par les
populations locales soient sur les
marchés dans les grandes villes il ya
différentes techniques de chasse il y à
la chasse au fusil mla le chasseur va
décider s'il tire ou pas sur une cible
mais il ya aussi quelque chose qui est
différent qu'il ne va pas directement
visé les grands singes c'est ce qu'on
appelle des pièges non sélectif
ce sont des collets donc comme des
noeuds coulants fait avec des câbles qui
vont être posées au sol avec un
mécanisme de déclenchement ou lorsqu'un
animal quel qu'il soit va mettre le pied
dans le collet ça a déclenché le
mécanisme est donc ça la tâche autour de
la pâte
ces câbles là vont pouvoir poser des
mutilations chez les chimpanzés chez les
bonobos donc ça peut dans certains cas
arriver jusque à une amputation c'est à
dire que au fur et à mesure il ya plus
de circulation sanguine et puis ça s'est
exposé puis la main par exemple ou un
doigt va trouver et ce qui est difficile
avec cette chasse là c'est qu' elle
n'est pas du tout fait pour faire du
braconnage sur les grands singes c'est
une chasse non sélectif et les grands
singes sont souvent des victimes
collatérales à cause des ses menace les
bonobos se retrouve en danger et la
majorité de la population qu'on a existé
des orphelins qui sont récupérés saisie
grâce au concours de de la loi comme
pour les autres grands singes les
bonobos ils vont ils ont besoin d'être
très proches de leur mère jusqu'à au
moins 4 5 ans parce qu'ils ont
énormément de choses à apprendre avant
d'être autonome pour combler sa au
sanctuaire ce sont des mères humaines de
substitution qui vont accompagner ces
orphelins pour les aider à se développer
[Musique]
non la vie balande à la cena pour la
poire et american vale
c'est des petits qui psychologiquement
sont traumatisés à cause de la mort de
leur maman ici le paradis en fait à sur
cette réhabilitation psychologique
d'orphelins afin de permettre une bonne
croissance jusqu'à les ramener dans la
vie sauvage
[Musique]
son plein d'énergie et ça c'est même un
indicateur primordial dans la santé pour
prouver qu il réellement
[Musique]
le sanctuaire va permettre de faire de
la sensibilisation bien sûr ça va sauver
quelques dizaines d'individus ce qui est
très bien ce qui est très important mais
c'est pas ça qui va sauver directement
la population
ça va y contribuer par la
sensibilisation notamment des écoles et
donc apprendre aux enfants et puis au
grand public en général que cette espèce
est menacée et qu'il faut la protéger
mais attention quand on parle de milieux
naturels
il faut pas non plus penser qu'on va
réintroduire des bonobos qui ont été
élevés par des humains avec des bonobos
qui n'ont jamais été élevées par des
humains ça pose des questions de santé
majeur des bonobos qui ont été élevés
par les humains ont pu avoir des
traitements antibiotiques
antiparasitaires mais aussi être porteur
d'agents pathogènes potentiels pour les
populations de bongo sauvage
donc là encore c'est quelque chose de
très compliqué qu'on ne peut pas juste
faire comme ça malgré les efforts de
conservation tous les grands singes
d'afrique de l'est et d'afrique centrale
reste menacée et c'est pour cette raison
que la primatologue française sabrina
krief continue d'alerter le monde sur
l'urgence de la situation
[Musique]
ça fait une vingtaine d'années que ce
travail en ouganda et chaque fois malgré
la longueur du voyage j'ai vraiment une
impatience est aussi une appréhension à
retrouver cette forêt parce que je me
demande toujours ce qui va pouvoir avoir
changé le parc national dans lequel
travaillent sabrina krief est un des
derniers espaces forestiers en ouganda
ou des chimpanzés et d'autres espèces de
primates peuvent s'épanouir
mais l'augmentation de l'activité
humaine dans la région met en danger la
vie des animaux
cette route elle traverse le
nationale 2 qui valait c'est une route
nationale qui est comme une sorte de
cicatrices dans cette forêt et qui
entraîne plaint de menaces à la fois les
risques pour les animaux de se faire
renverser de se faire heurter c'est
aussi une menace parce que les voyageurs
jette par les fenêtres
leurs bouteilles d'eau les particules de
plastique ont contaminé l'environnement
et les plantes qu'ils vont consommer se
trouve pollués par ces particules de
plastique
le fait que les chimpanzés soient
exposés à cette pollution peut expliquer
que certaines femelles ont des problèmes
de fertilité on a trois femelles dans le
groupe qui ne se reproduise pas qu'ils
n'ont pas de cycle et qui n'ont pas
d'enfant on peut évaluer la pollution de
l'environnement par l'analyse de l'eau
des rivières par l'analyse des crottes
ou des urines des chimpanzés ou bien par
leurs poils en fait le problème qu'on a
c'est qu'on ne peut pas faire de prises
de sang aux chimpanzés sont des
chimpanzés sauvages
on garde dix mètres de distance avec eux
et donc on a besoin d'un 10 indirects et
ses poils nous ont déjà révélé la
présence de molécule présente dans les
plastiques
donc c'est un indice de l'exposition et
de la contamination des chimpanzés par
les plastiques
[Musique]
ce
on voit sur ces images des chimpanzés
qui ont la face plate qui ont les
narines complètement atrophiée rentrée
ce qui n'est absolument pas normal ce
sont vraiment des malformations
congénitales qu'on voit à la naissance
qui ne sont pas liées soit à des
problèmes de génétique soit des
problèmes infectieux
mais qu'on attribue très probablement au
fait que pendant la gestation la mer
chimpanzé expose le foetus à des
pesticides
un mélange à la fois de pesticides issu
du maïs probablement et des plantations
de thé qui fait qu'il ya une espèce de
cocktails chimiques qui est présent dans
l'environnement de la mer chimpanzés
c'est absolument révoltant de penser
qu'on implique une telle pression sur la
forêt par l'expansion de l'agriculture
par l'utilisation intensive de polluants
chimiques
l'autre chose qui est vraiment alarmante
c'est que ce sont nos plus proches
parents et que si on observe çà chez les
chimpanzés mais aussi chez les babouins
probablement que nos frères primates
nous envoie aussi un signal d'alarmé par
par ces images
[Musique]
on a quand même une grosse difficulté à
voir des aires protégées efficace parce
que c'est des très grandes forêts parce
qu'un manque de moyens parce qu'un
manque d'infrastructures manque de
communication est aussi souvent parce
qu'il ya un manque de prise en compte
des populations locales
les personnes qui font la conservation
intégral qui la gère les grandes ong de
conservation ou les gouvernements en
sont conscients et de plus en plus
fondée consultation avec la population
locale
mais encore aujourd'hui ces
consultations sont plutôt ce qu'on
appelle de l'acceptabilité c'est-à-dire
convaincre les populations riveraines
que ce qu'on fait pour eux et bien ce
qui est très différent de chercher à
penser le projet au départ en prenant en
considération les pratiques les usages
qu'on les populations humaines de leur
environnement en ouganda il ya des
solutions des choses qu'on peut mettre
en place bien sûr enlever les pièges
dans la forêt ramasser les bouteilles
mais surtout faire de la prévention est
également faire en sorte que une
agriculture plus durable biologique
puisse être mises en place tout ça va de
pair bien sûr avec notre consommation
ici si on choisit des produits issus des
régions tropicales que ce soit le thé
bien sûr mais aussi le café ou le cacao
qu'ils soient issus d'une agriculture
biologique durable qui protège la santé
et les revenus des populations locales
donc commerce équitable ont fait un
geste énorme
les grands singes sont des espèces
charismatique emblématique de la
conservation en général le grand public
va être plus compréhensif à les protéger
des bonobos des chimpanzés ou les
gorilles cas les protège et l insecte
spécifique de tels frais donc à travers
la conservation des grands singes on
peut aussi agir à la conservation de la
biodiversité en général ces grands
singes qui sont des espèces
charismatique sont aussi des espèces
qu'on appelle parapluie comme son nom
l'indiqué prend on protège cette espèce
qu'on en protège beaucoup d'autres parce
qu'ils ont besoin d'un habitat assez
complexe pour pouvoir vivre les grands
singes joue aussi un rôle écologique
majeure ils ont un rôle de dispersèrent
de graines pour les chimpanzés ou les
bonobos par exemple ils vont consommer
plus d'une centaine d'espèces de plantes
différentes et pour une certaine partie
d'entre elles ils vont disséminer les
graines donc ils vont pas les manger
elles vont passer à travers leur
appareil digestif et quand elles vont se
retrouver dans leurs crottes à un ou
deux kilomètres plus loin de là où ils
ont mangé ça va permettre la
régénération forestière
[Musique]
j'ai espoir parce que pense qu'on ne
peut pas les laisser disparaître ce sont
nos plus proches parents les grands
singes sont les espèces les plus proches
de l'homme
si on n'est pas capable de protéger nos
plus proches cousins qu'est-ce qu'on va
réussir à faire alors avec le reste de
la biodiversité
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il est encore temps de
pouvoir réagir
[Musique]